thank you to the person on the Greece's
a book tour who gave me the shirt I love
it very much making up things I love
let's do a favorites video the hair from
the front looks awkward more than normal
there's some hair okay this is an
interesting choice grace this wasn't
thought through all the ways that look
do I look like a girl on the go that
like just kind of is effortlessly know
just stop there that's not it's not
gonna be true no matter what sure this
is fine let's talk my favorites I have a
bunch of favorites I'm out of breath oh
my god I'm getting too excited this is
how my dog feels okay I have a lot of
favorites so let's just jump right in
yeah yes see I can't say yes yeah I
mentioned this in my never have I ever
tried girly things
this is NARS radiant creamy under-eye
concealer I love it it works very well
lots of beauty gurus have talked about
it that is how I learn to try it this is
the color of vanilla this is the second
lightest shade and I only got this color
because they didn't have the latest
shade Chantilly which is coming to me in
the mail Who am I to know names of
things who's getting too excited again
Hough did my dog and I Freaky Friday
anyway I think this is great I like my
under-eye concealer like I like my
dramatic films something with some
weight to it this is like masking tape
to other under-eye concealers scotch
tape next a cafe oh yeah yeah I act as
one overly anxious thing to another you
need to calm down I shadow for book tour
I invested in a bunch of eyeshadows
because I thought I would try and make
myself overcompensating ly presentable
for meeting you guys and I found a bunch
that I like on a lower drugstore end
range covergirl is making these new
eyeshadow palettes whoo this one's
called roses and it's all kind of like
purpley pink shades this one's called
Golden's and it's all golden shades and
then there's one called nudes that's the
only one who didn't get I have enough
nudes in my life there's a lot of
mirrors in my house and I don't like
clothing and they're really cheap and
they're really
and pigmented and they go on well and
laughs pretty decently all day so I like
them very much on a higher-end scale
this is the Kat Von D interstellar
palette watch this
black bow Wow oh don't worry this hand
isn't covering up a mirror it's a naked
photo of Liam Neeson I like to look at
inspiring things when I'm doing my
makeup look at how pretty those colors
are it's very interesting there's some
Browns some purples some Silver's those
are cool yeah yeah
yes see I can't say 'hi FC is is Koch's
luminous dewy skin mist whoo the
prettiest dude love them all I saw this
in a Michelle Phan video and then I
immediately went on Sephora calm and I
bought it because that's how easily I am
persuaded by the nickel for every van I
got in as a child oh my god what oh I
hate myself I spray this onto my face
before I put my makeup on and it just
feels really good it feels very
hydrating very light and it smells nice
it is a little expensive but it feels
that way the packaging feels really nice
and I feel like wow I'm invested in
something that is very nice for myself I
must like myself sometimes cute next
yeah you say yeah say yeah this too chic
it's called too chic really this is
Giovanni's eco chic haircare dual
moisture complex avocado plus olive oil
ultra moist dual action protective
leave-in spray so many words you guys
but this does really nice things from my
hair I bought this at the grocery store
how ironic is it that I had to go to a
grocery store to get something to make
myself not gross I sprayed it in my hair
when it's damp after I take a shower and
I think it does nice things
avvocato and olive oil are supposed to
be really good for your hair and your
skin and all that good stuff and this
seems to be doing a good job and I've
used like half of it already
so that means can't stop won't stop next
yeah
yes I can't say I'm saying making of
oils this is oil of oregano I mentioned
this in my fried areas on tour mamrie
Hart gave me this oil of oregano but I
have since bought my own bottle this is
supposed to be
good for preventing colds or if you
start to feel sick for kind of knocking
it out before it has a chance to have a
conversation with your body feels like
the good buddy that tells you to swipe
left I put a few drops in water in the
morning and at night and I just take it
to the face I think it does a good job I
don't know for sure but I didn't get
completely blown out sick on book tour
and I was taking this pretty regularly
so if I'm good at math which I am NOT so
that and that thought next me guess I'll
say okay yeah these are and I'm so I'm
so nervous about recommending anything
food related because I know that freely
banana girl has a lot of opinions about
a lot of things and look I respect her
opinion I just definitely know that she
does not respect mine and I don't want
to be yelled at but these are really
delicious these are individual justin's
maple almond butter packets and i like
them a lot they make me think i have
some kind of like portion control or
just general control in my life at all
when it comes to peanut butter but i eat
all the packets and Justins almond
butter is delicious
they make original flavored maple
flavored and vanilla flavored and I
really like the maple flavored ones can
you spare me banana girl next yeah yes I
can yes ASA
pinky petals cover-ups ie nipple hats I
wear a lot of sports bras because I'm
not the most ladylike but when you wear
sports bras and there's a temperature
change your nipples
sometimes um don't just go with the flow
they're like that friend that doesn't
realize how loud they are and sometimes
you just need to like put tape over
their mouth these are like a tape over
your loud friend's mouth but for your
nipples
I brought these on tour with me and they
work really well so well that I ordered
a whole bunch of them when I got home
from Amazon I think you can reuse them I
just wipe them down with like a damp
cloth and you can put them on a bunch of
time I like them very much that's enough
of me talking about nipples next me
can't say yeah yeah say yeah yeah say it
chew these are some of my favorite shoes
that I've gotten recently these are
little ankle boots that I got from Zara
that I really like because they feel
very Coachella
without having to go to Coachella and
with the little fringe on the back they
make my feet feel like tiny Clydesdale
legs how romantic
then there's babies I got from Primark
over in London for eight pounds when I
was there they're high top pleather gray
sneakers super super lightweight and
they might fall apart at any moment but
that's the fun of it you never know what
moment and will that moment shape the
rest of your life in a negative way who
knows and then these I just got these
from Urban Outfitters they're little
yellow moccasin type shoes they're super
lightweight I have a feeling you're not
supposed to wear these outdoors at all
because I already did once and they've
already done that these might not last
very long at all whatsoever but they're
really cute for right now and obviously
I like this color is that it they do it
I think I did it okay that's it for this
favorites video let me know what you
guys were loving this month and oh I
still need to name this Friday I haven't
decided on something yet so it just give
me a little bit more time I'm working on
decisiveness too but you'll know as soon
as I figure it out okay because right
now I don't know there's no good for the
time being until I destroy you
completely I'm so sorry but you've
served this country well meaning me my
body cute